hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it was
the 9th of sep tember today and let's
talk about some apple stuff that's the
tech brand and not the fruit although
now that I think about it that might be
better so those of you keen on idevices
the big news of the moment is that Apple
has announced the new iphone 6 and a
larger version called iphone 6 plus the
iphone 6 is coming packed with a larger
4.7 inch high res screen and is
available in 16 64 or 128 gigabyte
version if you want the giant a1 the
iphone 6 plus has a 5.5 inch screen and
all those same storage sizes but it does
come with UI changes juice with size the
new phones will have a 64-bit chip which
will among other things facilitate much
better-looking games hey look we brought
the story back to games if you want to
see just what these games might look
like you should check out vainglory from
super evil mega corp on the new device
best name ever which was used to show
off its performance at apple's keynote
for more details on the phones check out
our story on site sony are continuing to
stress their commitment to destiny
saying that they're treating the game
like a first-party release bungees
multiplayer shooter may technically be
multi-platform but sony UK managing
director Fergal gara told Eurogamer that
is so much more than that to them saying
we're wrapping our arms around it on all
levels of the organization it's a
special project and an important project
and it has the power to launch Christmas
it's hugely important Sony is of course
pushing the game so hard because of
their partnership with Activision which
has resulted in an awful lot of
PlayStation exclusive content gaara has
expressed that he thinks destiny will be
a system seller for the playstation 4
and if you couldn't already decipher it
from his weird phrasing deemed it to be
a launchpad for the upcoming holiday
season next up the xbox one is due a
slew of improvements and the October
update is set to deliver on at least
some of them Xbox of Major Nelson
detailed the updates package which on
the surface includes better
to tasking while gaming small ways to
chat to friends and perhaps most
excitingly new options for accessing
your media the xbox one snap mode is set
to become easier to access enables
friends list viewing while in game along
with the ability to respond to messages
and the achievements app is updated so
you can share and compare all your game
II successes azva TV and video the xbox
one will now have support from media
player DLNA and the MKV file format as
well as digital TV tuner support as per
our question of the day let me know if
you reckon devices like the new iphone
is set to bring more gamers over to
mobile gaming or not and why if you're
after some more stories we've got bits
and pieces on battlefield 4 and madden
NFL 15 on site those are all the good
things that i want to tell you about
today I'll be back tomorrow with a bunch
more news but be sure have a good one
until then